jumping on the bus is something Millions
do daily but in Ukraine that routine
comes with risk
when the rocket hit I was getting ready
for work with my husband thank God two
walls saved us more than 20 people were
injured after the early morning strikes
residential and Industrial targets were
hit
about an hour south in zapparizio region
rubble and bodies a horrific but all too
familiar scene
he says he heard the strikes around
three in the morning three explosions he
could tell it was nearby the men here
are asked how they survive they say
there's no option it's just how it is
air raid sirens in the capital are now
accompanied by snow and power outages
repeated Russian strikes on the nation's
power grid have left many without heat
Ukrainian officials say four cruise
missiles were shot down by air defense
systems over Kiev along with five drones
it's not just Ukraine keenly focused on
security the president of Poland took to
the site of Tuesday's deadly missile
strike in person meeting with those on
the ground at the grain facility in the
small village in the country's Southeast
Andre Duda again stress the incident
appears to have been an accident
resulting from Ukraine's air defense
system
it is an extremely difficult situation
and it is not a surprise to anyone that
there is a lot of emotion here Ukraine
disputes the preliminary findings and
dispatched its own investigators joining
polish and American Crews on the ground
Crystal commencing Global News London